estar si me permiten voy a darles la
espalda y voy a tomar una foto de este
auditorio
ok
sí por favor
la van a encontrar con el hashtag
barrios altos usted por barrios altos
con esta fotografía voy a lograr
conectarnos a todos aquí
porque de eso se trata de una historia
de eso se trata la historia de mi
familia de la conectividad
en primer lugar quiero agradecer
pero a su gente
por la solidaridad el cariño
y la hospitalidad que hemos recibido mi
familia y los 426.000 venezolanos que
hasta el día de hoy han llegado a este
país
según la ong cáritas para febrero de
habían 6 muertes semanales de niños
recién nacidos por falta de atención
médica y por desnutrición en honor a
ellos y a mis 18 compatriotas que
fallecieron atravesando el páramo berlín
de colombia para llegar a pie a perú
quiero dedicar estos minutos que voy a
compartir con ustedes
quiero compartir la historia que
iniciamos mi esposo y yo
para llegar acá y dar a luz a nuestras
gemelas martín y marcel as que nacieron
en la maternidad de lima
justamente en barrios altos
y nos ha dado la oportunidad
de que ellas y nuestra hija ivana de 9
años crezcan en un país libre
nosotros en noviembre de 2017 cuando yo
tenía 6 meses de gestación ya nuestros
ingresos no eran suficientes para cubrir
los gastos de alimentación y educación
de iván a
la falta de medicinas y alimentos
hacía inviable que mi embarazo múltiple
se desarrollara con normalidad
por otro lado yo manejaba
de manera confidencial porque soy
periodista cuentas de empresas y
personalidades de alto perfil muchas de
ellas vinculadas al sector económico lo
que me hacía vislumbrar la crisis social
y económica que atraviesa en este
momento mi país mi esposo renunció a su
trabajo como director creativo de un
importante estudio de diseño en caracas
para dedicarnos en exclusividad a hacer
nuestro crowdfunding para salir del país
con dos teléfonos android y una
planificación estratégica muy extrema
nos dedicamos
aplicar tres principios del design
thinking
la empatía la ideación y la
implementación
empatizamos con nuestros amigos de
facebook que fue el público a quien nos
dirigimos
fue la plataforma que usamos para
difundir nuestra campaña que traducimos
del castellano al inglés y al francés en
segundo lugar
ideamos una estrategia que nos
permitiera conectar la tecnología
y precisamente nuestra audiencia a las
personas que queríamos que nos ayudaran
y ahí nos encontramos con un desafío muy
importante en latinoamérica la mayoría
de las personas considera que un
crowdfunding significa pedir dinero lo
asocian casi que con mendigar entonces
pusimos como ejemplo muchas empresas
privadas exitosas del área tecnológica
que han usado el crowdfunding como parte
de su estrategia el plan de negocios
para la implementación
apelamos a tres aspectos nuestro brawn
profesional lo emocional
lo informativo
así como
usamos el tiempo para llevar nuestra
información
tomando en cuenta los husos horarios de
las personas a las que nos íbamos a
dirigir
usamos herramientas audiovisuales
disponibles online como vídeos propios
transmisiones en vivo en tiempo real de
los controles prenatales de nuestras
gemelas
también actualizaciones sobre el avance
del crowdfunding de la gestación y
información actualizada sobre cómo iba
avanzando la crisis humanitaria y de
salud que actualmente atraviesa mi país
apelamos también a hacerle llegar
nuestra campaña a personalidades
de la política del entretenimiento y del
periodismo que la difundieron y nos
ayudaron no solo a recibir dinero sino a
hacer entender que más importante que
una colaboración monetaria es la
difusión la difusión de la campaña la
difusión de la idea la difusión de una
causa
luego
tuvimos un bache que vencer y explicar
estábamos en pleno diciembre en
temporada alta de viajes teníamos un
presupuesto para viajar y resulta que
literalmente de un día para otro los
pasajes aumentaron al doble así que una
vez que ya había arrancado la campaña
tuvimos que duplicar la meta que
queríamos alcanzar y eso tuvimos que
explicarlo
abrimos una cuenta de gmail que en ese
momento sirvió a los efectos de registro
y de notificaciones para la plataforma
cohone y ahorita
esa cuenta pertenece a martina y marcela
es donde les enviamos sus fotos sus
recuerdos y algunas cosas que su papá y
yo les escribimos
como se dan cuenta los niños antes de
nacer en esta época ya tienen identidad
digital
nuestra
reto
más allá de conseguir los fondos para
los boletos fue enfocarnos en que las
personas comprendieran que crowdfunding
es economía colaborativa financiamiento
colectivo basado en la conectividad
llegamos en 29 días
a conseguir donaciones de 15 países más
de 600 years facebook más de 5 mil
visitas únicas a la campaña en la
plataforma del golfo cnm y la mantuvo en
la plataforma siempre como una campaña
muy popular
y pues el 14 de diciembre de 2017
aterrizamos aquí en lima
barrios altos nos atrapó desde los
primeros días que llegamos porque
comencé a hacer mis controles tres veces
por semana en la maternidad de lima
allí conocimos personas que pese a ser
muy humildes aún hoy en día nos escriben
y están pendientes de martina y marcela
y nos han ayudado en la medida de sus
posibilidades
hoy en día martina y marcela
además de ser peruanas tienen derecho a
viajar en venezuela ellas no tendrían la
oportunidad de tener un pasaporte por
eso muchos venezolanos han llegado aquí
sin pasaporte
identificamos en
en la
en los medios digitales la oportunidad
de salvar vidas mediante la conectividad
porque la solidaridad
el querer dar no tiene fronteras no
tiene banderas
nuestra campaña aún no ha terminado
desde el momento que salimos de
venezuela nuestro propósito es aportar e
integrarnos a este país porque las
grandes economías mundiales se han
impulsado con la inmigración
en venezuela dejamos bienes materiales
afectos y un pedacito de nosotros pero
las oportunidades de progreso y libertad
que tenemos aquí vale la pena todo lo
que quedó atrás y si bien nos dimos
cuenta que bill gates nunca donó un
dólar por ese mail sobre la niña enferma
que alguna vez a todos nos llevó si nos
dimos cuenta que la conectividad puede
salvar vidas gracias
[Aplausos]